ZACH: My name is
Zach, and I have
the honor of introducing Minh
Tsai-- founder and CEO of Hodo
Soy-- who's here to
talk about his journey
from investment
banker to tofu master
and the growing
popularity of tofu
and soy products
here in America.
I first met Minh
several months ago,
taking a tour of his
tofu factory in Oakland
with a small Google group, and
I wanted to kind of bring this
to other Googlers
in Mountain View who
weren't able to make the tour.
It was very inspirational
and eye-opening for me
to see firsthand how he
grew this thriving business
from the ground up with
his passion for great tofu
and his risk to leave a
financially-stable position
and pursue his dream here.
So it's found everywhere in
Michelin star restaurants
to the aisles of
Costco and Chipotle
sofritas and our Google cafes.
Hodo Soy is revolutionizing our
understanding and appreciation
of tofu here in America, and
Minh is really leading that.
So without further ado, welcome.
MINH TSAI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So I have about an hour.
Right, Zach?
ZACH: Yeah.
MINH TSAI: OK.
Perfect.
So it's up to you how you
want to spend that hour.
I can spend a whole hour
talking about my transition
from investment banking to tofu.
I can talk about tofu-making,
history, economic, chemistry.
So let's do a show of hand.
OK?
How many of you want
to know about my story?
OK.
How many of you guys want
to know about tofu-making
and taste good tofu?
All right.
OK.
So why don't we focus
on those two areas?
You know, and then I'll weave
in the history and all of that.
And I'm going to try
to do that while I'm
cooking at the same time,
which is not an easy task.
So let's keep on this
show of hand business.
How many of you guys were in--
knows where tofu comes from?
AUDIENCE: Soy.
AUDIENCE: Soybeans?
MINH TSAI: Soybeans.
Excellent.
Good answer.
That was an easy one.
What about geographically
where it comes from?
AUDIENCE: China.
MINH TSAI: China.
Great.
Yes.
And how long ago have we sort of
discovered, so to speak, tofu?
Anybody want to
venture to guess?
AUDIENCE: 4,000 years ago.
MINH TSAI: Yes.
That's pretty good.
Nobody really knows,
but 4,000 is close.
And guess what?
That's pretty much
roughly around the time
that we actually have a
recording of people eating
beans, any kinds of beans.
Do any of you guys eat beans
and cook beans at home?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MINH TSAI: How do
you cook beans?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hmm?
MINH TSAI: How do
you cook beans?
AUDIENCE: Boil in water.
MINH TSAI: Boil in water.
For how long?
AUDIENCE: Forever.
MINH TSAI: Forever, exactly.
Well, the guy who discovered
tofu did it the exact same way.
So if you actually read
about any history of tofu,
which I know you
haven't-- but don't worry,
because in a few months, Olivia
Wu is going to bring in the guy
who wrote a "Book of Tofu."
I highly encourage you
guys attending his talk
because he wrote this
amazing book that talks
about the history of tofu.
But he doesn't know where
tofu comes from either.
So we're all speculating.
But essentially,
somebody somewhere
is cooking beans the same way
that everybody cooks beans.
You soak it, because
you get the dry beans.
Right?
And the reason it's
dry is because we want
to store it for a long time.
And the more mature
the beans are,
the higher the amount
of protein in the beans.
So universally,
we all eat beans.
And we eat it in a
similar fashion, which
is we soak it and we cook it.
And the reason we do
that is because the beans
themselves don't want
us to digest them.
So there's this thing called the
"Ipsen inhibitor," which means,
in our body, we don't have
all the enzymes and everything
chemically to absorb all
the nutrition of the beans.
As such, we have to cook it.
Because if you eat raw
beans, like uncooked beans,
you can't digest it.
You're going to
have a lot of gas.
OK.
So we cook it the same way.
So he'll come back, and I
have to save this part for him
about where it comes from
because this is like the raison
d'etre of tofu.
But yes, so it's an
accidental discovery.
OK.
And I'll tell you
why in a minute
when the chef comes back.
In the meantime,
I'll just skip ahead
and tell you tofu in America.
How's that?
So I said earlier, there's
this guy named Bill Shurtleff.
He wrote the "Book of Tofu,"
and it was published in the US
in 1976.
Some of you might
even have it at home.
But it's a seminal
book about tofu.
And in it, he talks
about how it's
made, where it comes from,
the amazing varieties of tofu.
And he essentially ushered
in the first generation
of Westerners eating tofu.
Thank you, chef.
So now, we skip away
from Bill and come back
to the guy making tofu in Asia.
So he's cooking a pot of
beans, and he's probably not
very well-versed in cooking it.
So he had some excess
water, and then he
didn't want to waste it.
So he drained that, tasted it,
and it didn't taste that good.
It tasted kind of beany.
And then he thought,
oh, maybe I'll
add something to make it
taste better, like salt,
the first natural flavoring.
He added salt, and
it tasted better.
So you have a
savory soy milk kind
of thing, a savory bean juice.
And he started thinking, well,
maybe I'll add something else,
like vinegar.
That's another flavor.
And he added the acidity of the
vinegar, and what he discovered
is this protein became a solid.
So the first Chinese
word for tofu,
it's actually called
[CHINESE], which means
"the flower of the beans."
And you see me do that--
demonstrate that later.
So when you drop any
acid into any protein,
it could be cow milk
even, it becomes a curd.
So what he essentially created
was the first bean curd.
So that's an accidental
discovery of tofu.
So if you read
the history books,
it says some prince wanted
to impress the emperor
and introduced it.
And none of that
is probably true.
Probably some
accidental discovery.
That's my theory, and I'm
sticking to it, because I'm
the tofu master now.
So now going back to Bill
Shurtleff, who introduced
tofu in the US.
Some of you heard this before.
So tofu was consumed in
Asia for thousands of years,
and then it basically went
from China to Japan, Korea,
all throughout Southeast Asia.
And it followed all
the Asians, or the east
and the southeast
Asians that traveled
beyond Asia, like to the
US, to Africa, everywhere.
And so tofu was brought along.
So when Bill Shurtleff wrote
the "Book of Tofu" in 1976,
it wasn't like tofu
didn't exist in the US.
It was around for
a hundred years
before Bill wrote the
book because the Chinese
and the Japanese have been here
farming and building railroads.
And they have tofu in
the Asian supermarkets.
But then the Westerners
really don't shop there.
And even if they
did, they didn't
know what it was if they
could find it in the grocery
store in the first place.
But Bill wrote this book,
and everyone thought,
oh, my god, tofu, awesome.
I want to eat tofu.
Where do I find tofu?
And the trouble was, you
couldn't find tofu in the US
after you read this
book, this amazing book
about how delicious,
how amazing tofu is.
And so Western companies
started making tofu.
So basically, he
introduced tofu,
and people couldn't find tofu.
So most people who
were brave enough
would go to Japantown and
Chinatown and buy tofu.
And imagine this
scenario if you're
buying tofu for the first time.
Your friends is telling
you, oh, this is amazing.
You know, you should go
to Chinatown and get it.
You go to Chinatown.
You venture into
a grocery store,
and you're looking
around for what
you think is a white block.
Because in the book, it
didn't have any photos.
It's just a drawing
of a block of tofu.
OK.
So you've never seen it before.
So you go, and you're
looking a white block.
And you look on the shelf.
You don't know
how it's packaged,
and you couldn't find it.
So you'd probably go home,
and you'd tell your friends,
I couldn't find it.
Or if you were brave
enough, you would actually
go up to the checkout stall
and say, I'm looking for tofu,
and then the person
at the checkout
stand-- because tofu
is tofu everywhere.
Right?
The word is the same in
Chinese and any language.
The person will understand
you and say, oh, tofu.
And you say, yes.
And then he would say, OK.
And he would grab a plastic
bag, if you were lucky,
and he will put it
around his wrist.
And he will stick his hand
under a bucket right next to him
and pick up a block
of tofu in his hand
and reverse the plastic back
and tie and hand it to you
like a block of gold fish.
Now, if you're lucky.
If you're not lucky, he would
just take it with his hand
and put it in the plastic bag.
But that is how most
Westerners experienced tofu
for the first time after
the publication of the book.
So you would take the tofu
home, and you're like, OK.
What do I do with this?
And often, at the time, either
you pan fry it or you grill it.
And if you happened to
be grilling something
and you bring it home
for a vegetarian eater,
you'd throw it on the grill.
And of course, it's going to
fall right through because it's
jiggly, jello-y, like a block,
because it was not the firm
tofu that we're used
to eating today.
So after the Western
companies started
making tofu in the early
'80s, what they decided to do
is actually make the
tofu and then pressing it
so that it's firmer and firmer
to become more meat-like.
So we Americans are
very innovative.
We invented the firm
and the extra firm tofu.
And the reason we
do that is because,
30, 40 years ago, we don't
have the Food Network.
We don't have a lot
of culinary programs.
People just don't know
how to cook as well.
We just came out of the whole
ready-made food, canned food
in the '50s, which
people didn't know what
to do with food in general.
They were eating a lot
more industrialized food
at the time.
So cooking was not
something that people
do at home so much, and
also definitely not tofu.
So most people didn't
experience tofu
the way it needed to be
experienced, which is like, oh,
what is it?
So now, you have Western
companies making firm tofu
to be more meat-like.
Where I'm going with this
is because the whole book
introduced tofu as
a vegetarian food.
And I usually joke
that it's kind
of like writing a match.com
profile and saying,
you know, I went to a good
school, and I have a good job,
and I'm smart and I'm fun, but
never say I'm good looking.
You know?
Like, I'm hot.
Because the way he
introduced tofu,
he didn't really
say it tastes great.
And unfortunately, for
him, in the "Book of Tofu,"
the people who subsequently made
tofu didn't make a great tofu.
And it's not their
fault, because they
were making a vegetarian
food first and foremost.
They were making
a meat substitute,
but they were also making a tofu
as a very unusual and new food
that economically need to align
to what tofu costs in Asia.
So they were also
making a cheaper tofu.
So between the introduction
of tofu as a vegetarian food,
between the economic
of tofu, most people
actually don't want
to pay more for tofu.
So tofu costs about a
buck a block 40 years ago.
It's about a buck a block today.
So when you look at
the economic of tofu,
there is a disincentive
for anyone making tofu
because there's
no market for it.
So you have a whole
generation of people
who are really
enthusiastic on eating tofu
and then encounter
poor experience
eating tofu and then raising
kids who are like, no way.
I'm not touching that.
My mom made terrible
tofu turkey.
So you can't blame them
to not eating tofu,
and you can't blame tofu
for not sort of rising.
There are many other types of
food that are very similar.
I bet most of you guys all
know that lobsters used to be
a prisoners' food in the '50s.
You know, it wasn't
a gourmet food
until a gourmet chef decided
to make it a gourmet food.
Same with calamari.
People didn't want to
eat squid until someone
called it calamari.
Now it sounds so much better.
So you know, sushi, same thing.
People didn't like
eating raw fish
until somebody came and
said California roll.
But now, people are going back
to eating raw fish again--
a purer form of sushi.
So food comes in these
really funny cycles.
Tofu is the same way.
It was introduced,
and it wasn't very
well-thought out in the
introduction process.
Because Bill, again,
when he wrote the book,
it was more about
saving the planet.
It was about eating a
plant-based food that's
going to save the planet
because we were having
all kinds of issues raising
enough food for the rising
population.
And also, it's the time.
Right?
Today you guys are
much more conscious,
not just because
you're here at Google,
but you're in California.
You're in the Bay
Area, and you want
to know where food comes from.
You want to know about
health and nutrition.
There's so much more information
out there, thanks to you guys.
People are much more
conscientious today,
and they can access
information a lot more.
And from the
culinary standpoint,
it really helps people
to really understand
cooking and nutrition and
everything else better.
So while Bill is a
product of his time,
and tofu and other forms
of food, back in the days,
also go through that funny
sort of like acceptance frame,
Hodo is a product of
our time, of my time.
So we're very successful
if you look at us
and you don't know who we are,
and you're like, oh, my god.
Hodo, Chipotle.
We've been around for
10 years, but it's only
been the last five
years that we began
to see the rise of
tofu consumption again.
Because after the
introduction of tofu,
what you have is a chart where
a lot of Western tofu companies
were built, and then the
industry started in a decline.
And it continued to decline
until about 10 years ago.
And I'm an economics student.
So when I started to
think about making tofu,
I was very crazy
in that I wanted
to make a delicious tofu that
I grew up eating in Vietnam.
So for me, definitely,
that had to be the case.
Make a tofu that
tastes good, because I
couldn't find good tofu.
But I also understood
the economics
of tofu, which I'm going to go
into now while this is still
getting warm.
Perfect.
So tofu, as an
industry in the US,
after the rise of those
Western tofu companies,
people discovered that it sort
of had this really interesting
split.
You have some companies
that just are mom
and pops companies,
small tofu-makers,
very similar to Asia, which is
you make it for that community.
And then you have companies
that wanted to grow,
and most of these tend
to be Western companies.
They want to distribute
beyond the Bay Area,
beyond their community.
So you have this split
between small mom and pops
and then a company growing
big into multimillion dollar
businesses.
But what is the difference is
that all of these companies,
despite the fact that they
have an economic split,
they make very similar tofu,
which is a cheaper form of tofu
because of that competition.
Your mom and pop shop
can make better tofu,
but because of no
economy of scale,
they have to make it as
competitive as the tofu
you would find at a supermarket.
So if you have $1,
you need to figure out
whether you want to spend it
in the supermarket or locally,
assuming you can
find it locally.
So tofu-making, you'll
see in a minute--
and you can also go
on Google and find
a lot of videos of us-- it's
really interesting, because you
can't be somewhere
in the middle.
You either are a mom
and pop or you really
have to grow to be
sustainable because
of the investments required to
build a production facility.
You cannot make tofu
in small, small scale.
So you have to make
it in big scale.
And there are sort of
industrial safety standards,
like a boiler, for example.
We have rules here that
if you want a boiler that
generate more than five
horsepowers of steam,
you need this massive
room that's bulletproof.
And when it explodes,
nobody gets hurt.
So a lot of tofu-makers,
when they cook their soy milk
using steam, had to either be
under five horsepower-- most
of them are-- or way bigger.
So that's one example
I want to give you
in terms of how you built.
And also, it's very
labor-intensive to make tofu,
because to mechanize it
costs even so much more.
You would have to
spend $5 million
to start a tofu business if you
want to mechanize everything.
So because of that split,
you have the small guys
and you have the big guy
and nobody in between.
And the small guys are
always struggling to survive,
and the big guys basically
dominate the market
in the grocery store chains.
And at the time, chefs don't
really use a lot of tofu.
So you basically
have a retail market,
but essentially dominated
by the big guys.
So they dictate the
price, the texture,
whatever tofu you're getting.
And you have the little
guys, who basically,
after the first
generation-- like San Jose
Tofu-- the kids don't want
to take over the business
because it's really hard work.
And we've seen this
over and over again.
I pretty much know 60% of all
the tofu plants in the US,
and I hear this story
over and over again.
While I'm trying to get
people to build tofu business,
they're going under faster than
I can get people to build it,
and the reason for that
is purely economics.
So when I started this
business, in my mind,
because of my banking background
and consulting and economic,
I knew that I did not want
to build a small plant,
but I also didn't want
to build a big plant.
I wanted to build something
right in the middle
because, if I'm correct,
which I have been so far,
this is the hardest
space to be in.
So that's my barrier to entry
to starting my business.
OK.
So it doesn't mean I don't want
somebody else to do what I do.
I would love to have another
business doing what I do,
because I think the
industry is young enough
that, if you have people
making delicious tofu,
you get more people eating it.
And I've proven that because
most of our customers
initially are
actually new to tofu.
And how we began to think
about winning our customers
is focusing on taste and not
on everything else that people
are focusing on-- vegetarianism,
veganism, meat substitution,
any of that, or health, even.
So what I end up
making is a tofu
that tastes-- hopefully, to you
as well as to me-- really good.
And that takes us into the
whole chemistry of tofu.
So to make a good-tasting
tofu, how many of you
guys have traveled to
Asia and eaten tofu there?
China or Southeast Asia?
OK.
Japan?
Excellent.
Did you eat tofu
of any form of tofu
when you were in Japan or China?
AUDIENCE: For several years.
MINH TSAI: OK.
There you go.
You want to be sitting
here answering Q&A later?
And was it delicious when
you ate tofu in Asia?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MINH TSAI: OK.
And did you find the
same type of tofu here?
AUDIENCE: Trader Joe's
actually isn't too bad.
MINH TSAI: OK.
AUDIENCE: And San
Jose Tofu is fine.
MINH TSAI: Exactly.
San Jose Tofu makes great tofu.
I agree.
So it's really not that
easy, at least, for me.
I have very high
standard for tofu.
So I couldn't find it.
That's why I decided to make it.
But one of the first things you
need to do to make good tofu
is actually the soy milk.
Because people are not
familiar with the taste of soy,
your first introduction
of soy milk
is probably Silk, which is
a very successful company.
And they've managed
to basically take
all the flavors of
soybeans out and make
it taste as close to
cow milk as possible
in order to sell soy milk.
So that's a battle I'm trying
to basically go against.
And right now, I can
say I'm winning today.
But now, for the
last 9.8 years, I've
been losing, because
what I'm trying to do
is actually make people enjoy
the flavor of the beans.
And in Asia, when we eat a
tofu and we drank soy milk,
we wanted that.
We want, mmm, this
is really beany.
This is really fragrant.
So when I make a tofu,
that's what I emphasize on.
Because I didn't want
it just to sell it
to people who think of tofu
as a meat substitute, who
can cover up, whatever.
You add flavors to it, and
that's a flavor you're eating.
It's just a vehicle
for that flavors.
I hate it when people do that.
Like, eggplant is a
vehicle for flavors.
Tofu is a vehicle for flavor.
No.
Every single one of these items
actually has a distinct taste.
You just haven't had an
opportunity to taste it.
So that's what we do at Hodo.
As sort of tofu ambassadors,
we want people to say, oh, wow.
You know?
I didn't know that
tofu has a taste.
And not only that, I didn't know
that it can taste this good.
So that's what we try to
do, and to do that, we
need to make a yummy tofu.
So we start with the soy milk.
To get really good soy milk,
you need a thick soy milk.
It's kind of like whole
cow milk versus skim milk.
Most tofu companies today,
because of economics and yield
and whatnot, use something
much akin to a skim milk
to make tofu.
And you can do that because
you add more coagulant,
and it becomes a chalkier tofu.
So that's essentially
the difference.
Really good tofu
is very pliable,
which means that you
actually favor the milk more
than the coagulant.
The proportion is different.
For our tofu, we use
about 1% coagulant.
Most tofu use probably
closer to 4% or 5%.
And you can see it
in the protein level
if you look at the
nutritional panels of tofu.
If you buy our firm tofu,
it will say about 16,
17 grams per serving.
Most tofu don't even
get to double digits.
So the whole soy milk, so
that's the first thing we do.
And all our soybeans we
actually source from farmers
in the Midwest.
We contract them to grow
it for us every 12 months.
So we work with a
large cooperative,
and we probably
source from a dozen
different small organic farmers.
And we'll commit to
that going forward.
So do you guys
have any questions
so far before I launch
into tofu-making
and talk more about chemistry?
Nobody's falling asleep yet.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You guys are organic.
So you have no source
of GMO product going in?
MINH TSAI: Everything we source
is 100% organic and non-GMO.
All about ingredients.
Wherever we can.
If it exists, we'll get it.
We are the most expensive
tofu, but it's not very
expensive relatively speaking.
All right.
So what I have
here is a soy milk.
This is the soy milk
we use to make tofu.
And what I needed to do is I
needed to heat it up first.
And when I heat soy milk,
what I have is [CHINESE].
And some of you have seen this.
This is essentially
the cream of soy milk.
If you drink Straus
milk, you still
get the cream that
rises to the top.
This is essentially
the same thing,
because cow milk has
all that protein.
The difference is,
chemically speaking, is this
is a much more
pliable, flexible piece
of sort of cream
versus a cow milk cream
is much more brittle, so it
doesn't have the elasticity.
So this can be manipulated
into all kinds of stuff,
like you guys had
for lunch today.
So I'll put this aside.
AUDIENCE: There's
some cups here.
MINH TSAI: Oh, yeah.
Put it into the cup.
Yeah.
Somebody can eat it.
It's yummy now.
So to make tofu, besides the
milk, we need a coagulant.
You see how this
is sort of settled?
This is gypsum.
[KNOCKING]
The "plaster of Paris,"
as they call it.
Except plaster, or gypsum,
is actually a mineral.
It's basically calcium sulphate.
This is a pure food-grade
form, so don't worry.
And we use this because this
is the original coagulant found
in Asia, in China.
And it's a mineral
in the ground.
And the reason that the
Chinese started using this
is because they also flavored
the beans themselves.
This is one of the few
minerals cheap enough
to get that does not mask
any of the bean's flavor.
It brings it out.
It allows it to stand alone,
the flavor of the soy beans.
If you go to Japan,
you might have
had a tofu that's made with
what we call nigari, which
is a calcium magnesium
chloride, which
is a byproduct of sea salt.
And the reason the
Japanese use that
is because they actually
didn't have a lot of calcium
sulfate in Japan.
So they had to use a
different coagulant,
and the chloride
there sometimes leaves
a slightly bitter flavor.
That's why some people
originally called
that coagulation a bittern.
The term bittern is from that.
I'm shaking it up because
calcium sulfate is not
a water soluble.
So I need to sort
of keep it mixed.
You see why.
Any questions so far?
No?
Mesmerized?
[CHUCKLING]
Just kidding.
All right.
So normally, this is where
my colleagues are like,
don't need to measure this out?
Like, I'm a tofu master, man.
I know how much this
is going to take.
Watch me screw this up good.
All right.
So I have that, and I'm
going to pour some in here.
Because it's not
a water soluble,
I need to mix it somehow.
So besides mixing it
here, when I pour it
in here, when I pour
the soy milk in there,
it needs to mix as well.
So this is where the "tofu
master" title comes in handy.
Don't do this at home
without supervision.
So I have the calcium
sulphate in there.
OK.
And as you can see, it's already
settling again, but that's OK.
So the milk needs to be heated.
And the reason we
need to heat the milk
is, when you heat
any liquid, the atoms
are flying all over the place,
and that's what we want.
So when we pour it in
here, we want those atoms
to be loose and start binding
with the calcium sulfate.
That's essential.
So I have a gallon
of soy milk here.
AUDIENCE: What temperature
did you heat the milk?
MINH TSAI: Great question.
So it needs to be roughly
about-- I usually heat it
beyond kill step, which is 165.
So when it's super hot,
it doesn't help either.
So generally, it's
about 165 to 185.
And so here is the hard part.
And actually, I'm going to do
it here so I don't hurt myself,
and you can see better, too.
I'll bring it up front.
So you have the coagulant here.
And when I pour it, I want
to pour it in a steady form.
So somebody said, which is
true, the hardest tofu to make
is the softest tofu.
And I'll explain
why in a second.
So I'm going to
pour it, and I want
that pouring to be mixing
that calcium sulfate in there
without splashing.
I want you guys to
applaud when I'm done.
See, it's actually
mixing naturally?
Where is the applause?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So if I did a better job, you
wouldn't see the bubble on top.
And the reason we-- I say
the hardest tofu to make
is the softest tofu is,
if you get this wrong,
it's not going to
be that smooth.
It's going to be like, what I
said, the flour, like chunks.
You have some protein
that didn't really
coagulate with the
coagulant, and you basically
lose some of that protein.
So here, in about
one minute, it's
already forming into a solid.
And the reason that it's
harder to make this is,
if I mess this up-- which I
didn't-- I can always just pour
all of this into a
cheesecloth and squeeze it,
and it becomes a
firm block of tofu.
See?
So if I don't get this right,
I can still make firm tofu.
But I cannot make soft tofu.
I have to-- a
completely new batch.
So here, I'll jiggle it.
See that?
Now, you have a choice.
Oops.
Nobody told me.
You have a choice.
You can eat that, or I
can make it into tofu.
AUDIENCE: I wanna eat that.
[LAUGHTER]
That's not tofu?
MINH TSAI: This is tofu.
This is silken tofu.
AUDIENCE: Silken tofu.
MINH TSAI: OK.
Now, to make it in a block
a tofu, I break that up.
I put it in this really
beautiful wooden mold
with a cheesecloth, and I
turn it into a block that big.
You can eat that tofu, too.
But I can tell you, from
personal experience,
that this might be just the
most delicious tofu you've ever
eaten.
And if we have
time-- oh, we do--
I can make another tofu thing.
I'll boil some more soy milk.
So you guys want
to try eating that?
I highly recommend it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MINH TSAI: So I'll leave
you to the serving.
AUDIENCE: Oh, sure.
AUDIENCE: Will we have
to use those cups.
MINH TSAI: It is.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
Excellent.
Yeah.
So imagine me
growing up in Asia.
There's another spoon
if you want to use it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How big
should the scoops be?
MINH TSAI: Oh, you can have a
bigger scoop because people are
going to want bigger pieces.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
When I grew up in Asia, somebody
walks around with a basket,
yelling "tofu," and
that's what they
were selling hot with a
little bit of ginger sauce
or something.
But I didn't want to
give you guys ginger
sauce because I didn't want
to mask any of that flavor.
AUDIENCE: So what is the
method of making the soy milk?
Because you've boiled
the beans and then--
MINH TSAI: Great question.
AUDIENCE: And then
grind it or something?
MINH TSAI: Yes.
So to make soy milk, we
basically soak the milk
overnight until it's
completely rehydrated.
And then we grind it into
a slurry, like a mush,
sort of like an oatmeal mush.
And then we cook it at
a very high temperature
so that it's cooked.
And then we separate
the beans from the pulp,
and then we extract the milk.
This is a very
traditional method
of making tofu, because
in modern day tofu-making,
for efficiency's sake, some
people just soak the beans,
grind it, separate it, and
then just cook the milk.
But we actually have a
double extraction process
where after we cook
the beans, we actually
don't throw away the pulp.
We actually rinse it again
to extract it a second time
to get more flavors out of it.
So that's what we
do to maintain.
What do you guys think?
AUDIENCE: All good.
MINH TSAI: It's
pretty amazing, right?
Yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: It tastes better
than what they serve here.
How do they ruin it?
MINH TSAI: Hey, you're
sitting next to a chef.
No.
The thing is, you
can make that here.
You just need to
buy our soy milk.
And in fact, some chefs
have down it here before.
And again, you have the
opportunity to eat it, like,
made on the spot.
But if I leave that-- and
you'll see, in a few minutes--
that will actually started
leaching water soon.
So here what I started
out with a bind, what
I would say close
to a perfect bind,
meaning that I'm not
wasting any soy milk or any
of the coagulant.
Now, if I put too much
coagulant, you know,
it's going to be chunky.
If I put too little, it's not
going to be a smooth cream.
So because I'm a tofu
master, I've got it down.
But over time, that bind will
actually start splitting,
and you're going to get
water as a byproduct.
So tofu leaches
water all the time.
That's why, when I talk to the
chefs at Green's Restaurant--
they've been around.
They've used tofu
for a long time.
They buy our "extra firm"
tofu, and they marinate it
in a broth for a whole week.
And it's still only
on the surface.
So I talked them into using our
tofu, because I said to them,
I said, at least after people
eat your delicious flavoring
marinade, they still have a
delicious tofu underneath.
Because before, you had a
delicious flavoring marinade,
but you had a terrible
chalky tofu underneath.
So that's the goal here
is, for the longest time,
I didn't want to make a
firm tofu because it's
so hard to work
with, because people
don't know how to use it.
The firmer it is,
the harder it is
in terms of textures
and flavor for people.
But finally, I said, OK.
People really want a firm tofu.
How can I make a firm
tofu that actually tastes
better, at least better to me?
And if you actually do a tofu
taste test with our tofu--
again, the firm tofu-- you will
actually taste the following.
You will taste first a
really beany, nutty flavor,
because it's there.
I don't try to hide it.
And secondly, you'll
taste a slight sweetness
of the beans themselves that
you won't taste in other tofu.
So you'll see a nutty, beany,
buttery sweetness to our tofu,
and that's why I think
people begin to buy our tofu.
And it's only a matter of time
because you get a better tofu
from Trader Joe's, if I have
my ways, which I think I do.
Oh, that's being recorded.
Everything's
recorded these days.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what's the
difference between using
sprouted beans or just--
MINH TSAI: Oh.
You ask all the best questions.
They planted you here.
OK, how many of you guys eat
sort of like sprouted stuff?
OK.
I love sprouted stuff.
I love any kinds
of young shoots,
whether it's vegetables
or anything that's young.
It's just tastier.
But here's the problem with
sprouted when you cook.
What happens when you
cook something sprouted?
All that nutrition is gone.
It's the most brilliant
tofu marketing
I've ever come across.
[LAUGHING]
It's so true.
So what happened was-- again,
it's totally accidental.
I've seen this.
We've soaked beans, and we
couldn't use up the beans
because the machines are down.
So we don't want to waste
300 pounds of soybeans.
We stick it in the refrigerator
overnight, over the weekend.
Sometimes, we forget about it.
And guess what happens
when we forget about it?
AUDIENCE: Waste?
MINH TSAI: Exactly.
Do we want to throw that away?
No, we don't.
But we still process
it the same way.
We still cook the
heck out of it.
So all that nutrition of raw
and sprout, it's all gone.
But it's brilliant, because
the company I came up with it--
and I won't mention names--
that's exactly what happened.
Their machine went down.
Most likely, they
had tons of soybeans,
and it took them a week
to fix the machine.
And they have sprouted soybeans,
and they used it anyway.
But nutritionally
speaking, there
is no advantage, unfortunately.
But any types of bean sprouts--
because what happens is,
when a bean itself
starts sprouting,
the chemistry of that
bean changes and it
allows for better absorption.
Nuts, same thing.
Legumes.
All legumes, when it's
sprouted, it's saying,
OK, I'm going to give up now.
You can eat me.
And you can digest
me much better.
Right?
But then if you're going
to go ahead and cook me,
then all of that, no.
But I love the marketing.
One day, we're going to
come up with sprouted tofu,
too, when I have enough space
to actually let beans sprout.
So-- but that's
a great question.
Any other questions
before the next batch?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
And we actually
used to give tours.
We work a lot with Bon
Appetit to give tours,
but we're growing
so quickly that we
sort of took over the tourist
base, which is about this size.
And now it's our
employee lounge.
So in a few months,
we'll co-opt it back,
and we can do more tours.
And I've come now and done
culinary classes with Chef
down here before.
Olivia Wu, who's a huge advocate
of us down here, talk to her.
She'll bring me down.
I don't say no to her.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
And usually, for that class, I
do a little bit more in-depth
about textures and flavors-- you
know, have handouts and stuff
so you can understand.
Because I don't do a lot of
consulting because most chefs
don't actually ask
a lot of advice
because they have gone
to culinary school,
and I'm not a chef.
But I'm happy to provide any
advice when it comes to tofu.
We're almost ready
for the next batch.
Can somebody do me a favor
and actually pour this out?
Because I can't use
that up anymore.
Yeah.
I just need a--
AUDIENCE: This poured out?
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MINH TSAI: That you can leave.
So if you can pour that out
somewhere, that would be great.
AUDIENCE: It's like
that birthday cake.
MINH TSAI: So you
can just eat it.
Yeah.
Can you guys see the water
there that's leaching out?
That's essentially what happens.
AUDIENCE: Is it hot?
MINH TSAI: It's not hot.
It's lukewarm, but
it's still good.
Tofu does not get
spoiled because, when
you finish making
the tofu, it's still
at what we call not
in the "danger zone."
So when it comes to any types
of food, they call it 140/40.
So you want it to be below 40
degrees F or above 140 degrees
F. Anything in between,
it's when the food is more
susceptible to contamination.
AUDIENCE: Hmm.
MINH TSAI: So the beauty about
tofu is that, when you make it,
it's above 140.
So then the trick is, how
do you get it from 140 to 40
as quickly as possible without
it getting contaminated?
Most people don't
think about that.
The reason they don't
care is because most tofu
is consumed that day.
They don't leave it longer.
And then another way
you can sort of get away
with that is, if you put
the block of tofu in water,
it pushes water out.
And if you keep rinsing
that water in the bucket,
then that tofu has fewer
opportunity for contamination.
But tofu goes bad
really quickly,
especially if you use
a high protein tofu.
So our tofu, if we make it
the same way as other people
and we treat it, it
will go bad faster.
But fortunately, we
are very hygienic.
And so we actually have
the longest-lasting,
non-pasteurized
tofu in the world,
not because we put some
chemicals or anything in it.
It's because, as soon
as the tofu comes out
of the cheesecloth, that's
the first time that somebody's
touching it.
And as the probability
of contamination rises,
that's where we're
most vigilant.
You know?
The tofu cutting board,
the knife, the gloved hand.
They need to be changed,
the cheesecloths when used.
Blah, blah, blah.
And so as soon as it
comes out and it gets cut,
we put it in a package and
we cool it down very quickly.
So our tofu will we remain
relatively fresh and tasty
after 25 days.
And even the largest companies
that make tofu cannot do that
because, their whole process
is different than ours.
So we're very proud of
that, the ability for us
to make a tofu that will last
and stay fresh for a long time.
So any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I have a question, because I
went to Greens this weekend.
MINH TSAI: Oh.
Lucky you.
AUDIENCE: The tofu was awesome.
MINH TSAI: The brochette, yes.
AUDIENCE: And how
does your tofu get
to Greens, or to restaurants?
You come to them and say,
we have this great tofu.
We want it for your restaurant?
Or they reach out
to you and say,
we hear you have great tofu.
We want to use it.
MINH TSAI: Good question.
So as a company, I
will confess to you,
I'm a terrible salesman.
OK.
I hate sales.
But I'm a good teacher.
So I think the success of our
business is because I care
about teaching
people about tofu,
and I always try to get the
bigger guys with money to be
like, hey, you need to really
explain to people what the heck
tofu is and how to use it and
all of that, but they don't.
So Greens is the same thing.
They've used tofu before us.
And I basically say to them,
I'm like, how about I come in,
and I teach you about tofu?
And they also came to us because
we're at the farmer's markets.
I can talk a little bit about
that whole career thing,
if that's of interest.
What happened is I
started as an investment
banker in the early '90s.
And what I discovered--
I'm an immigrant kid.
So I came from Vietnam,
and I came here in 1981.
And I was very
fortunate to have gone
on to really great
schools and all of that.
So when I came out
of graduate school,
I wanted to work
in the Peace Corps.
I wanted to do development
work, actually.
Because I was a
beneficiary of so much,
like of the UN and UNHCR.
But at the time, most
of the professors
that I encountered in
my graduate program
came from really large,
organized institutions,
like the Peace Corps,
IMF, or the World Bank.
This is a time way
before, like Grameen Bank
and micro-financing
and community financing
and community development.
So most of them said,
dude, you're a young kid.
You have no experience.
You don't speak French, which
is the lingua required to work
in those international fields.
You should just go
to the Peace Corps
and just volunteer
for three years.
And I couldn't do that
because I had a lot of debt.
So I said, OK.
So how do I still do what I do?
So I managed to talk my
way into investment banking
because they needed a
lot of investment bankers
at the time in
Asia and Hong Kong.
And the projects
that they had me on
was to build
telecommunications businesses.
So this is the beginning
of wireless communication.
And in telecommunications,
there's a universal access
clause that requires any
builder of telecommunication
to designate a certain
percentage to people who
normally cannot access it.
If you live in the
countryside, there's
no reason for me to
connect you because you
don't bring any economic
benefits to me as a company.
But by law, I have to do that.
And so that's the piece
that I hooked myself into
in investment banking.
So I did that for a
few years, and I really
enjoyed it because I got to
travel all over the world
building wireless.
I had a brick of a
cellphone back at the time.
But I really enjoyed
it and learned a lot,
but it wasn't the
right culture for me.
And I left investment banking
because I learned a lot.
I went from one group
to another to another,
like from equity to emanate
to debt and all of that.
Oh, no wonder.
Two minutes.
You might not get to see tofu.
But I learned a lot,
but I got bored as well.
And so I quit
because I didn't know
why my bosses were
making so much money
and still working so hard.
No, it's true.
They wanted me to work on
Christmas, I still remember.
And I said, I was like,
no, I'm going home.
And they're like,
no, you have to work.
So I was kind of
pissed about it.
And then when I came
back and worked,
I found out how much
money they made.
They were making
$25 million a year,
and they worked
Christmas and New Year.
So there was a
discongruity to me.
So I was like, whoa,
something weird.
So I was like, I can't do that.
If I even make $3 million,
I wouldn't even be here.
So I left, and I went
to management consulting
because I wanted to continue
to work in telecom and learn.
So in that process
between when I
started my professional
career to when I quit
was about 12 years.
I saw four recessions.
It's like recession, three
years later, recession.
It was the dot-com
boom, and then burst.
So I was really
disillusioned by all of that,
because as my career
was taking off,
I realized that America has
is not the meritocracy that I
thought it would be.
So that's my final
disillusionment
before I started my company.
I never got laid off.
But every time that
happened, I saw
that the people,
my colleagues, they
stayed because of a lot of
politics within corporations.
And I was never politically
astute from that standpoint.
So in the end, I just thought,
you know, it's not fair.
So I left and decided,
to the chagrin
and the disappointment of so
many people-- started tofu.
People really
thought I was crazy.
They're like, you're
throwing away your career.
What are you thinking?
What is tofu?
Why are you doing tofu?
But in the end, I lucked out.
It worked out.
So I'm very lucky.
And it has so much to do
with timing-- the timing
at the farmer's
markets, the fact
that I decided to start
at the farmer's markets
was a stroke of pure luck.
Because people there had
money, so they didn't mind
paying for more expensive tofu.
They were very
curious about food,
and the farmer's
market proliferated.
Today, you have about 200
farmers markets a week
in the Bay Area.
Did you know that?
When we started out, 10 years
ago, there were like 20.
So there's a tenfold
growth of farmers markets.
But it's not good
for the farmers.
Because now, while
it's good for you
to roll out of bed to
get it anywhere you want,
that farmer has to
go to 10 markets
to make the sales
that he normally sold
at maybe one or two markets.
So it's good at it's bad.
All right.
Any other questions before I
make the final batch of tofu?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm
curious, because as you
said, when I see Hodo
tofu on the menu here,
and it's super firm and has a
different flavor from what's
here.
So are they selling
a different product,
or are they preparing
it differently?
[INAUDIBLE]
MINH TSAI: I think it's
not a different product.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MINH TSAI: It's
the same product.
I don't know how
it's served here.
So I can't really speak to that.
But what I can say is I'm
happy to come and sort of give
a talk about it.
Because what
happened, I'm afraid,
is people do too
much to our tofu.
People think, because they
set have the mentality,
I have to fry the
heck out of it.
I have to flavor it a lot.
But if you just cube
up our firm tofu
and just lightly dress it,
whether it's hot or cold,
it would do the tofu justice.
Because people take our
tofu and deep-fry it.
It's terrible.
You have a thick
coating on the outside.
AUDIENCE: Aburaage?
MINH TSAI: Aburaage?
Yeah.
Where is that tofu thing?
Oh, good.
I'm going to pour
this, and then I
can make my-- if you don't mind.
AUDIENCE: What would you like?
MINH TSAI: Just put that out.
I'm going to pour this in there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MINH TSAI: Sorry
to waste all that.
AUDIENCE: No.
MINH TSAI: You can still eat it.
Oops, sorry.
All right.
So here is our tofu.
How scientific.
I'll do that up here
instead of down there.
So first, I'm going to make the
exact same thing that you guys
saw, which is the silken tofu.
And while that's happening, I'll
set up this really nifty thing.
So essentially, what I do here
is I'm breaking up the whey.
It's very similar to
cheese-making, separating
the whey from the curd.
So this is just our cheesecloth.
I wet it because it's easier
to fold when it's wet.
That's always a trick
question I ask people.
Why do you think
I need to wet it?
It's just easier to manipulate.
So very quickly, as you can
see, I have somewhat of a silken
tofu already.
And then this is
the part where it's
a heartbreak for everybody.
Now, I started breaking it up.
You see?
I didn't do a good job.
You see how it's not very
creamy here when I rushed it?
This is what the
first guy discovered.
It's kind of like
these little chunks.
So it's not fully silken.
So that means, as I use this,
I'm wasting some of the cream
or the milk remain.
So now, I basically will
scoop these chunks in here.
And then I would press all
of this into a block of tofu.
AUDIENCE: When you press it,
are you pressing out water?
MINH TSAI: Exactly.
In this case, I will
actually press out
some of the remaining
proteins as well.
AUDIENCE: And what
makes it cling together?
It comes out as a solid
block, but it's going in as--
MINH TSAI: You
mean, what makes it
cling together here, or here?
AUDIENCE: When you press it?
Yeah.
It's going to come
out solid, right?
MINH TSAI: Exactly.
The reason that
it comes out solid
still is because,
as you can see,
I'm doing this when
this is still hot.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
MINH TSAI: So if I use that
silken tofu there and I
try to form this, it wouldn't
work, because that heat.
It's almost like a
second coagulation.
That's what it is.
And if you can do
it, basically, you
have to do it soon after
the the silken tofu is made,
otherwise it won't form again.
AUDIENCE: So your thickener
is the calcium sulfate?
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
It's calcium sulfate.
AUDIENCE: Is there any other
thickener that you can use?
MINH TSAI: You can.
As I mentioned
earlier, like, nigari,
which is magnesium chloride.
It's another coagulant.
AUDIENCE: What about like
lemon juice or vinegar?
MINH TSAI: Any
acidity will work.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MINH TSAI: But it's
also going to change
the flavor of your tofu.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In this case, this
has got absolutely no flavor.
That's why you're using it.
MINH TSAI: Right.
Exactly.
AUDIENCE: As I'm watching this,
comparing your process to how
we make [INAUDIBLE].
MINH TSAI: It's very similar.
AUDIENCE: I'm
drawing similarities,
that's why I'm asking.
MINH TSAI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is that
because the protein
has a different texture when
you use calcium sulfate?
[INAUDIBLE].
MINH TSAI: No.
You use calcium sulfate
to make the new-- no.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MINH TSAI: Right.
So basically, because
the milk has protein--
now, I haven't tasted your
panir, but I'm curious,
what is the flavor?
Does it still retain some of
the acidity of the lemon juice?
A little bit, right?
AUDIENCE: When I make it.
I mean for the amount we use.
We use about almost
200 pounds at a time,
so it's impossible to make it.
I'll get it.
I source it when I do make it
I do make it for small batches.
MINH TSAI: You can
definitely make tofu.
You can actually make
tofu using lemon juice.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
So actually, if you want to keep
this and play around with it--
AUDIENCE: Cool.
MINH TSAI: Yeah, please.
No, I'm always happy.
So then I just basically fold
it into a nice little block.
When we have our tofu
class, this is what we do.
We let you do this yourself.
AUDIENCE: Where
do you get these?
MINH TSAI: You can
buy them on Amazon.
So let me put it in there
and see what happens.
Sorry, guys, no tofu for you.
MINH TSAI: Oh, man.
MINH TSAI: This should work.
Sometimes, when you add water,
you can still make tofu.
Forget the block here.
This is why we innovate.
We have a round ball of tofu.
AUDIENCE: That's
how you make panir.
MINH TSAI: That's
Yeah.
It's going to be like cheese.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Spin it.
MINH TSAI: There you go.
So yeah, that water.
Oh, I guess I poured
water in there.
But essentially, this
is still pretty hot.
But the clearer the water
after the silken tofu is made,
the more perfect the
coagulation is, the gelling.
So let me do this.
It's too hot.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: If you add
something like an acid,
like lemon juice, what is
the need for salt as well?
MINH TSAI: You don't need salt.
So my earlier explanation
is he probably added salt,
and it didn't do anything
flavor-wise or texture-wise.
But when he added the--
AUDIENCE: Vinegar.
MINH TSAI: The vinegar, that's
when it becomes-- I'm so glad.
I did not know that you use
lemon juice to make panir.
Is that universal?
AUDIENCE: I mean, that's most
of the recipes that I've used,
and I'm just curious to see what
would happen if I used calcium
sulfate to make panir.
MINH TSAI: You
can still make it.
You probably won't taste that
sourness of the panir itself.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
tried flavoring the soy milk?
MINH TSAI: We have.
I was telling these
guys that we used
to have what we called savory
tofu, where, in this process,
I actually add flavor.
AUDIENCE: So as you're
boiling it, you also--
MINH TSAI: It's not
the milk, but in there.
AUDIENCE: In there?
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
I cannot do it in the
milk, because if I change
the chemistry of it too much,
it won't reconstitute the second
time.
In other words, if I manipulate
that flavor too much,
I won't be able to
get a tofu block.
AUDIENCE: Hmm.
MINH TSAI: So that's
the challenge.
AUDIENCE: So you--
AUDIENCE: Oh, sorry.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: You had
mentioned how you thought
you would be able to make
a tofu that was almost
indistinguishable from panir.
I was wondering what
sort of techniques
you can use to change, like, the
texture and flavor of the tofu.
What are our--
MINH TSAI: Actually, the
texture of panir and tofu,
the difference is one is
slightly more elastic.
The panir is more crumbly--
not too much more.
So there's the flavoring
challenge and then
the texture challenge.
I think the texture
challenge can
be overcome if I use
a different coagulant
and I add some salt to it.
Then it would be
slightly more brittle.
Flavor-wise, unless you
can remove the soy flavor,
it will stay there.
However, the reason
that panir tastes
so good, for me at least, is how
rich it is, how creamy it is,
and because of the milk.
AUDIENCE: Right.
MINH TSAI: So I would have to
use a really thick soy milk
to do panir, and that thick soy
milk will have enough protein.
And I would also try
to find a soybean that
actually has high fat.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MINH TSAI: Because not
all soybeans are equal.
So if I find a high-fat
soybean, high protein,
and I also would basically use
it-- make a thick soy milk.
Then I'm closer in
terms of the ability
to flavor it similar to the
flavor, similar to panir.
And then I would
start with that,
and then I would basically
work on the texture.
AUDIENCE: Well, we don't
want to have a brittle panir.
MINH TSAI: What?
AUDIENCE: We don't
like a brittle panir
because what we use--
MINH TSAI: Right.
Right.
Yeah, it'd be fun.
I'd love to come down and play
around with you, if you want.
We can configure our time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MINH TSAI: Don't you guys have
some kind of food research
institute here?
You have all kinds
of institutes here.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It starts off at 3 o'clock
when my staff leaves.
MINH TSAI: OK.
There you go.
That will work.
You know?
So--
AUDIENCE: Let's go
play in [INAUDIBLE].
MINH TSAI: But
here, you have it.
And you guys can
taste it, if you want.
It's just very
different, but what
I have here is a nice block
a cottage cheese-like tofu.
Look at that.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wow.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Whoa.
AUDIENCE: It actually
has the string.
MINH TSAI: The cloth.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's awesome.
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
Go ahead and try it.
Just take a spoon and dig in.
AUDIENCE: All right.
MINH TSAI: This is-- yeah.
Now, if you salt the soy milk,
it's harder to coagulate.
You have to salt it after
the second constitution.
In other words, you make
them-- you make the silken.
You break it up,
then you add salt.
And then--
AUDIENCE: Really?
MINH TSAI: Yeah.
That's good.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That's really good.
MINH TSAI: There's a
really amazing article.
I think it was written in
1980 in "The New Yorker,"
maybe even older.
But you can probably google it.
It's about this
journalist who went
to Japan to learn about tofu.
It's a really
well-written article.
And how it ended
was the tofu master
invited her to his mountain
retreat for the weekend.
And she went, and she discovered
that he was a wine connoisseur.
And he went to his
cave, and he brought out
a bottle of really expensive
Burgundy white wine.
And she was shocked.
It was like $1,000 bottle.
And she's like, we don't have
anything to go with this.
And he said, yes, we do.
And apparently, he served
her some aged tofu.
So I think he's dead.
Otherwise, I would visit him.
Thanks, guys.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]